the God of War TV series for Amazon it's
coming
this is what we know so far welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
thanks to my connections with um Amazon
and mg and I've been able to get a
little bit of an inside track on what's
actually being planned for the God of
War TV series Amazon are planning to get
their screens as soon as possible now we
know that this was announced recently
and that Hawk OSP and Mark Ferguson's
company penguin in a Parker would be
acting as executive producers would be
writing several episodes and would also
be developing the TV series for Amazon
Prime we also know that Rafe Judkins
from Wheel of Time will be showing now I
know what you're going to say
immediately
Wheel of Time as crap and uh
I kind of feel your pain on that one
Wheel of Time was Never As Good As It
was supposed to be and to be honest I
don't think Amazon ever really backed it
up with a proper budget it was
lackluster at times the acting wasn't
great the storyline wandered a lot of
people shouted woke at it but I'm not
touching that with a barge pole and
obviously Rafe goodkins was in charge of
that show so he's now in charge of this
show should we be worried no I don't
think so mainly because the expanse guys
hawkosby and Mark Fergus are also
involved and they're going to be running
a lot of the development we know from a
lot of the work they've done in the past
and hopefully fingers crossed the work
they're going to do in the future with
Stargate is generally excellent for me I
think they're just really good at
keeping things simple keeping things
close to the original content so
obviously keeping everything in Canon
actually respecting the original content
and they're just really good writers
they don't do anything big they don't do
anything clever they just to do stuff
well and to be honest that's always what
I want from filmmakers generally how
many times have you watched a movie and
you've thought ah why have they tried to
be clever why can't they just do a film
I want to watch watch anything Marvel
are doing at the moment and you'll
completely understand what I'm talking
about but what have my sources been
telling me about what's been planned
well the initial run will be hopefully
10 episodes but there's been a streaming
service Amazon have demanded that it
will be 8 to 14. that is the order that
is what's being contracted they're being
given a budget initially of 120 million
dollars so again how they spend that
money between the 8 to 14 episodes is
completely up to them creatively I think
that's really interesting because they
can adjust the budget depending on what
they want to do if they want to spend a
lot more special effects or do something
a lot bigger they can just do less
episodes they can boil down the dollars
to a minute and make something far more
focused that might be far more expensive
however if the show is going to be a
little bit more character driven and
they don't need that massive budget for
the millions of dollars of specials
effects Etc then they can stretch it out
and they can tell the story they want to
tell I actually think that's a massive
strength of streaming services and
something that I'm looking forward to
with lots of projects that are coming up
now God of War is something that you
might not actually know that well if
you're not a big gamer to be honest it's
not a game I've ever really played a
great deal it is obviously owned by
PlayStation and this project has been
worked on for a very long time we heard
as early as March last year actually
that this was being looked at I've
personally known that Mark Ferguson Hawk
Osby were going to be involved in this
since roughly April or May they've been
developing this for at least six months
but I also know that there are a few
issues currently at the moment Amazon
are desperately wants in this project to
be getting going as quickly as possible
they're actually pushing for a late
spring filming schedule to start now my
sources have been telling this for a
little while and actually if you're a
regular site Trekker you'll know that
that is seriously currently affecting
negotiations with my favorite show
Stargate penguin in a Parker and the
production company involved in producing
the show are pushing back a little bit
and are hoping to maybe film um late
summer to have this show on our screens
perhaps towards the end of 2024
Amazon are really really pushing however
for early 2024 or late 2023 now for a TV
show this Grand with post-production and
the special effects that are going to be
required
I think 12 months to produce this TV
show is ambitious to say the least but
possible so let's see what they do but
who is going to play some of the main
roles in this series well the name has
been banded around a lot is Triple H now
the main character from the God of War
series is the Kratos character Kratos
Kratos however I want to say that
and he is in the game played by
Christopher Judge I have nothing more to
hide will you be the gods we choose to
be
Stargate bringing you back every every
chance I get to mention Stargate I'm
taking it at the game awards Christopher
Judge actually recently worn best
performance for his portrayal in God of
War Ragnarok of Kratos and I mean his
acceptance speech literally won World
Records
um it was push in eight minutes he did
really go for it
um and I just love him and I just love
as well that even though he took the
gold off his forehead he put it on his
shirt instead gotta love that so anyway
Christopher George is a very popular
choice with the fans another popular
choice with the fans but less likely is
The Rock Dwayne Johnson now there's a
lot of fan art already out there as The
Rock dressed as Kratos Kratos Kratos and
he would be a very popular choice but
let's be honest that [ __ ] ain't
happening
another name though this gets banded
around the law is because the character
is a big fella and Triple H Hunter
Hearst Helmsley from WWE Fame is the
other name that seems to be getting
banded around a lot now when I used to
watch the wrestling when I was a wee top
wrestler I I just loved him
um I used to have the Triple H hat my
daughter lost it I lented it we were in
a pub she put it down she walked out
without it I never saw that hat again I
love that hat but anyway
Triple H I would have thought maybe 10
years ago would have got attracted and
he's done a few movies don't get me
wrong I actually really liked him in
Blade Trinity he played one of the
background vampires but he was really
cool in it uh that was the blade movie
that had Ryan Reynolds in it as well
it's actually I think the best of the
three it's really it's a shame it ended
the trilogy but you know blade Trinity
is just a great movie go back and watch
it
so
Triple H has cut his teeth on acting but
he's never really done anything else
he's never been the lead actor in
anything that was successful so could he
pull this off God I hope so because he
is war weary you know he has got the
scars to show for it he has got vast
experience if they were to talk him into
doing this I'd watch the [ __ ] out of it
the big thing here though is that if
Amazon really are pushing for filming to
begin as early as late spring I mean you
could say that's April May time we are
going to be getting some of the answers
to these big questions really really
soon and I can actually confirm that at
least one of the names I've just
mentioned is true and that Triple H has
actually been approached to discuss
whether he would be interested in this
part
let's see if that initial contact
becomes anything more Concrete in the
coming weeks because I am telling you
guys we are going to have to get
announcements in the coming weeks if
they're going to be filming this
anything like when Amazon would like
them to please go in the comments go and
tell me what you think of the God of War
project is this going to be a little bit
too similar to Warhammer 4K for you I
mean I gotta say that to the untrained
eye somebody that's not really into
miniature games somebody's not really
into gaming they look kind of similar
now that is going to annoy people let's
say how many comments I get based on
that statement but is it a risk that
actually only one of these two projects
can be successful
let's see if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also if you want to support the channel
and you want to go that little bit
further consider hitting the join Button
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]